so
uh i think mushrooms is a good place to
uh to ask about
my uh friend joe rogan so i keep folks
from the cardona community kept saying
keep saying things like uh lex podcast
first
then joe rogan experience uh i guess i'm
the moon and joe's mars in this metaphor
uh since i'm a cs person i can talk a
little bit
uh more fluently about cryptocurrency
because fundamentally
uh cryptocurrency is a computational
idea but then there's somebody like joe
who is more like an everyman he does not
necessarily know the technical
intricacies of cryptocurrencies
what kind of and i don't think he's had
a cryptocurrency person on
yeah didn't he interview andreas
antonopoulos oh he did that's right long
long time ago but that was almost like
um you know the cryptocurrency space
goes through phases
and i think we're in a new era of some
kind right and
what how do you talk to joe about
cardano
how do you talk to joe about what the
heck
i remember somebody tried to explain to
him what dogecoin is uh how do you
explain this whole space so what bitcoin
is
of where ethereum is or cardona smart
contracts and some of this proof is work
with us put the stake
ideas that we've been talking about you
don't what you do is you start with
applications that they're interested in
so he's an elk hunter and so he's
probably interested in elk tax right
so you start there and you say that
whole system can be put on a blockchain
and here's
how it's going to be better for you you
see that's what you do
you always connect it to something they
know and love and then once they get
that they say oh that's really cool
and then they ask what else can you do
with it what else can you sell me on it
and you kind of work your way outwards
there the problem technologists make
is they're so damn in love with the
technology they have that tail wagging
the dog where
they just want to talk about the
technology and how incredibly cool it is
and that's fun it's like talking about
math oh god let's talk about cool
boardism
that's fun all right like you need
everybody's eyes glio's over
no you always have to connect it to the
interest of the particular person and
what they care about what they love what
they need
royalty payments you know he's a big guy
he's got the spotify thing he's got all
these things going on
intellectual property is probably pretty
important to joe at some juncture so
nfts
we can talk about this concept of
perpetual royalties
so for example let's say that you create
a piece of art you can build into the
token itself
a perpetual royalty to something you
care about maybe
every time it sells it pays it back to
you or maybe
every time it sells it donates to some
clean water charity or something like
that
the point is that the actual acquisition
of the nft
requires adherence to that smart
contract so people can't deviate from
your desire even after you die
so you know stuff from andy warhol or
from picasso
that that can still be generating some
donation every time a picasso sells
to something else you can do that with
nfts and city starts thinking god what
else can i do i do shows maybe i can do
my tickets with these types of things
maybe i can do loyalty points for my
fans
so now you got to engage and he's
thinking all the opportunities for him
and it gives him an incentive to anchor
and connect to those concepts and
then over time he starts asking
questions well how do we know it's
secure
then we can talk about proof of work or
proof of stake or these types of things
well so this is how
it stays secure if you're really
interested and there's there's
an incentive to have the attention span
necessary to do the homework eat the
broccoli and get over that hill but it's
also an opportunity at least it was for
me
especially with bitcoin a while ago is
to
take another look at the monetary system
even look at the
you know i've been looking quite a bit
at the history of the 20th century
and sort of look at that history through
the perspective of the monetary system
the gold standard and all those kinds of
things and just add that little layer of
consideration
of how much money of how money can be
used
to uh by people in power to control the
populace right
and it's it's a it's fascinating to
look at the history from that
perspective and then that allows you to
look at the future of how we can change
that
in order to empower people and then of
course the
the the governance thing that you're
working on is fascinating because
i mean i don't know but it seems like
deeply broken aspect of our government
is just the voting system and discussing
how that could be revolutionized
is fascinating because a lot of
conversations end up being
on you know on the internet about like
number go up which is like financial
side
and to me personally at least i think
the that's the same for joe
is that's just boring like it's the
investing the financial side of it i
know it has a lot of impact but it's
kind of boring
right because long term is not going to
have any impact if the ideas are strong
long term it's going to win right the
ideas are weak long term is going to
lose
the ups and downs of the short term
don't matter that's just like
casino games uh that you play
you